what if I told you what you're missing
in 2023 is a real enemy you you're
missing an enemy you may have an enemy
you're not thinking about your enemy
what if I told you your business plan
goals everything you're doing for 2023
logically is not going to get the best
out of you unless if you have a force
opposition or somebody preventing you
from having your dreams become a reality
I'm gonna break that down for you today
with a few different stories about Messi
Pele Maradona and hopefully you'll
understand what I mean by you needing to
have 10 or so different types of enemies
[Music]
for some of you that are having a hard
time embracing this concept of enemy
stick around you're going to realize you
need an enemy everybody has an enemy
including Christians wait till I tell
you their enemies and it'll make sense
to you I'm 23 years old my friends are
telling me let's go to the club let's go
to the club let's go to the club girls
were coming to my place and I'm focused
on a meeting I'm having the next day and
they want to stay till God knows what
time and be a distraction to me that is
a form of an enemy if you're trying to
get in shape your friends who are eating
junk food and they're trying to give it
to you that is a form of an enemy
opposition to your goal of having a
six-pack by the time summer comes along
and again Christians claiming well this
is not a Christian thing to do
Christians have an enemy it's called the
devil the adversary it is an enemy
you're fighting the adversary every
space has an enemy by the way the bigger
of a thing you want to do in your life
the bigger the enemies you're gonna need
to have or you're going to have whether
you like it or not I'll give you a story
that just happened right now at the
World Cup World Cup who wins the World
Cup Argentina wins the world who becomes
the greatest of all time guy named Messi
do you know in a meeting with Pele and
Maradona a few years ago Pele Maradona
are standing they forget that the mic is
hot Pele is asking maradon of course you
should see this he says Hey What Can you
tell me about Messi I don't know a lot
about him what can you tell me about
Messi Maradona who is the hero he's the
god of soccer in Argentina tells Pele
yeah he doesn't have a personality and
then they start talking talking he
doesn't have a personality of a leader
Maradona later on says no one who goes
to the bathroom 20 times before a game
is a leader Messi's not a leader Messi's
not a leader and in Messi This World Cup
everybody kept saying why is it that the
first time we're seeing Messi play a
little angry why is Messi playing with
emotions why is he playing this way why
is he talking the way he does the game
with Netherlands goes in front of Van
Gogh and Van Gogh says hey you guys
cannot win with penalties we're going to
beat Argentina with penalties and
Messi's the first to kick the goal to
score it in the penalty shots while
Brazil when they lost Neymar went to go
last because he was already out of the
game but Messi was in the game he scores
the first and then he goes in front of
Bengali standing like this everybody's
saying why is Messi doing this in front
of Bengal and if you look at Van Gogh
he's looking this way Isaac van God
doesn't remember but Van Gogh is also
driven by enemies this was a
representation of a player 20 years
prior to that name rickelme that van
Gogh God who was a mentor type of a guy
to Messi whom Van Gogh publicly
humiliated and it's Messi's way up
saying I remember boom and then he wins
he proved Maradona wrong he proved
everybody wrong and he proved himself in
his country right by now being the
greatest of all time but maybe Maradona
was right and he's driving him who knows
the point is he had to find a real enemy
deep down inside to win the prize you
want to be the greatest of all time
which is messy now argument is over with
Ronaldo went to Saudi Arabia signed a
half the billion dollar contract and
he's doing what he's doing and Messi
imagine being worth 600 million dollars
you have every single record possible
pretty much you have all these Trophies
the only thing you're missing is one
freaking somebody may say stupid trophy
who cares about this but he needed that
to become the greatest of all time he
had to tap into a real enemy to produce
the Jews to go after this because the
pain the leadership the unification of a
team required to achieve this is so
above what you really think it is the
only thing you can do is you need to
find a real enemy that's going to
produce those emotions for you so now
let's talk about you who are your
enemies let me give you a few different
types of enemies and you make a decision
who drives you and who motivates you one
form of an enemy is an ex an ex who left
you for another man an ex who left you
for another woman an ex who didn't work
out an ex who did something to you
betrayed you hurt you it's their way of
saying I believe there's better men out
there than you I believe there's better
women out there than you because if she
didn't believe that why would she do
what she did hello that is one form of
an enemy you think you have an enemy
that's one by the way this doesn't mean
you color and you text you tell her what
she is and all this other stuff that's
not what this means this stays here no
one needs to know it's you
you got a point to proof maybe she's
right maybe she's not but you got to do
your part another enemy could be an
ex-business partner somebody that you
did a 50 50 partnership it didn't work
out and you were doing all the work he
wasn't doing all the work and you were
making the money for the company he was
not didn't work yet you got a bankruptcy
something happened to your credit that
is another form of an enemy an enemy
could be a relative a family member a
mom dad sibling somebody said that you
can't make it you're nobody you're just
a regular guy those words that a family
member or relative set that is a form of
an enemy an enemy could be a manipulator
somebody that came in between your
family I got a lot of manipulators in my
family that came in between my mom and
my dad they were manipulators that came
between my family they were enemies to
me as a 10 year old kid when both of
these sides would say oh he's Armenian
the other side would say he's a Syrian
and I would tell him there's only two
people that matter in my life my mom and
my dad and you're not a part of it the
only other person is my sister you guys
are relatives I'm only good to you
because of him and I'm only good to you
because of my mom nothing more than that
you're an enemy you split up my family
that drove this 10 12 14 year old kid
but because there's a form of an enemy
another type of enemy is somebody that
could on you maybe somebody was working
with you know all of a sudden they're
like oh you know what I'm not going to
work with you to go to a different place
to work with another person you know
what they're saying there's better
opportunities out there than working
with you that is a form of an enemy
imagine you're a sports team and a guy
says I want to go play with the other
guy a guy named Tucker leaves Miami to
go to Philadelphia to play with Joel
embiid Jimmy Butler goes out there on
Twitter calls him out on Twitter because
he jumped from Team to team to team to
team to team and I'm a fan of this guy
he's a great defender but to Butler
Tucker's an enemy you leave me to go
over there and you put a nice word no
publicly you're saying I think I have a
higher chance of winning a championship
with Philadelphia than I do with what
with Miami that is a form of an enemy if
you go to a different place another one
somebody that forces things on you it
could be an institution a government
that tells you better do this or else
force force force force force that is a
form of an enemy what do you want to do
about it I was watching Ice Cube say
something about he got offered to do a
movie nine million dollars you have to
turn it on because they forced him he
says they were forcing me to take the
jab so I had to turn down the movie nine
million dollars you should hear when Ice
Cube says this on a podcast it's an
obvious enemy for Ice Cube you think Ice
Cube is somebody that's driven by force
or Freedom he wants to be left alone
that is his enemy okay it's a form of an
enemy another one may be bullies you may
not like bullies maybe you were bullied
maybe you were bullied in business I was
bullied as a kid and I was bullied in
business as well I played both roles and
then I've realized what these guys were
doing and I learned their games and I
saw these big Behemoth goliaths in the
marketplace that I'm competing against I
said I got your game no problem you're
an enemy you're a Target let's have some
fun together with bullies maybe that
drives you it may not drive everybody
but maybe bullies drive you to become
strong and they leave you alone maybe
you don't even want to bully them back
you just want to be so strong that they
know they cannot mess with you and that
drives you that could be a form of an
enemy now these other three are all on
you because your enemy may be your own
ego you are your own enemy you get in
your own way all the damn time every
time by the way Alexander the Great I
have met the enemy it is I that
statement by Alexander applies to many
of us probably most of us because we get
in our own way of somebody's really
trying to lead you and give you
Direction you're not receiving it
because your ego is getting in the way
somebody's really trying to challenge
you to kind of become a better leader
but you're fighting it you don't think
they're on your side that is also a form
of having an enemy another mindset could
be that's also on you as an enemy is
your scarcity mindset you're afraid
you're secretly scared you're secretly
that six-year-old kid that is afraid you
know how you used to think you had
monsters under your bed you may be 42
years old today and you still have a
form of thinking there's monsters under
your bed you have a scarcity mindset
that's holding you back that is a form
of an enemy that is you versus you and
last but not least your Last Enemy you
ready you're simply content you're
content here's a guy named Messi's worth
600 million dollars imagine the cars
he's got in the garage beautiful family
kids goes to restaurants doesn't pay for
it everybody wants to have dinner with
them everybody will wants to meet him
everybody wants to interview him
everybody wants his attention living a
dream life anybody in the world would
say Messi's life is a dream life but to
Messi deep down inside by himself
everybody tells him how great he is by
himself when he's in the bathroom
Nobody's around he says you're content
you convince yourself you don't need
this trophy you know sometimes you talk
to NBA players do you need to win the
NBA championship to be considered one of
the greatest point guards of all time I
don't think I need that Championship
content
the language even Barkley who never won
a championship he himself said if you
don't win a championship you can't be in
those categories you have to win a
championship Barkley who could
manipulate her to kind of favor himself
said no you need to win a championship
to get that level of respect right Messi
has to sit there and say I think you're
content man he's saying it to himself
nobody else can tell him that who's
going to tell Messi you're content tell
me one person qualified to tell Messi is
content there's only one person
qualified to tell him that only one it's
himself and maybe you're content with
where you are and you're like not
willing to recreate yourself and improve
are you going to New Year another
contentment type of a I'm doing okay I'm
doing better than my dad I'm doing
better than my brother I'm doing better
than my mom I'm doing better than my
classmates and your content by the way
that just may be your number one enemy
but whether it's any of the ones I just
shared with or the first one you may
want to like make a list of it yeah how
many times I've done this names that
drove me 20 years ago I don't even think
about today things that drove me 15
years ago as enemies today I forgot
about it today I'm reminding myself
while I'm making this video today and
I'm telling you some of these stories
the clubs my friends I have two names in
my mind names that drove me 10 years ago
don't drive me today or things on this
list from five years ago but I created a
vision board last week in this crazy
vision board that I was making last week
had faces on it that I would have never
put on a vision board because I am more
driven by enemies that are holding my
kids back from their dreams becoming a
reality with a certain socialist mindset
or trying to impose certain beliefs on
them those are enemies that generate
incredible energy for me at 44 years old
while I'm the wealthiest I've ever been
I have the best life I've ever had but I
need those for myself so if Messi needs
it if musk the richest man in the world
needs it if people like myself needs it
maybe you need it as well what do you
think so take a sheet of paper take the
PDF from today on 10 different types of
enemies and start writing things next to
it names and all that stuff anyways so
if you want to get the PDF from today's
episode click here so you can make the
list of your enemies or watch another
video like I did I want to say four or
five years ago titled how to go up
against the Goliath of your industry if
you've never watched that video click
here to watch it take everybody good
luck with your enemies
[Applause]
[Music]